you have an eight-year-old and this
would concern me your eight-year-old has
seen you as the character negan and you
recently discovered your eight-year-old
dressing up yeah yeah me again
yeah that would disturb me as a as a
parent it's it was an easy outfit a
leather jacket and some boots and a
baseball bat maybe a baseball bat but
he's never seen negan do pounds yeah do
bad stuff he knows that on the walking
dead he's been to set and made everybody
and but he knows Uncle Norman and all
that but yeah one day I had I'd lost him
and just he was at we have a farm Annie
oh good yeah he's gonna say you have a
larger property so he was just often it
when you like if you say that like I'm
in New York City and I lost him no don't
think you're a bad dad his clothes I
knew he was close he'd been gone for
like a couple minutes and I'm like
worried where'd Gus go and I'm looking
around the property for him and I see
him coming out of the chicken coop with
his negan outfit on leather jacket and
boots and a baseball bat and I'm like
Gus what are you doing and he's like I
was playing eenie meenie Moe with the
chicken oh my god so I immediately like
I throw down whatever I'm doing and I
run past him into the chicken coop to
take a head count everybody was fine but
yeah that's just the kind of an average
dad or maybe just get him a therapist he
knows the negan's done some things for
instance the et meenie miney mo but he
never saw the result yes yes I don't
want to know about yeah you shot rampage
with the rock a dude and your son
obviously like many kids probably a big
fan of the rock yeah well is now for
sure
yeah yeah did he get to meet him he did
he met Dwayne when we were doing all the
the press leading up to the premiere of
the film Gus came and hung out with me
while we were doing funds of interviews
and and I introduced Gus and and Dwayne
to each other and and Gus kind of sizes
him up and he looks over at me and
like dad I think the rock could take you
I'm like yeah uh boy yeah you don't have
to be that smart I mean I'm sure he's a
smart boy - look at the rock and look at
any one of us I think my money's on the
ride he's very observant son and after
that of course where I'm with Dwayne for
like a month to impress and every time
he would see me or we do an interview
together Dwayne would look over at me
and be like you some things I can take
you yeah he must say that to everybody
he doesn't know when I congratulate you
just had a baby girl I did how recently
she's seven months old yeah yeah yeah
both my girls right there what is what
is her name her name is George Virginia
George Virginia George Virginia is a
cool name it's a good name right yeah
yeah even better it's gonna be a tough
start but you know either way yeah my
dad named me Conan and it all worked out
it look good exactly
we like code yeah
you